Mark: But we if you're with me I've got the guns so that at least we can survive.
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: Alright, I'm gonna move carefully.
Wade: (nasally voice) I'm just a scientist.
Mark: Okay, I'm gonna pretend that didn't happen. Uh, I'm-
Wade: Why?
*Laughter*
Wade: Come on... Buddy! Homie! Main-man!
Mark: Jesus Christ. Just stop please. I'm gonna move carefully-
Wade: I have 3 PHDs.
I'm going to move carefully *breaks into laughter
Wade: Where???
*Laughter*
Bob: Jesus
Mark: (high-pitched voice) I'm gonna move carefully!
Bob and Wade break into Laughter
Bob: Effects! Effects!
*Everybody saying "Effects!"
Mark: It's also- Ethan, this is good for you!
*A bunch of bleeped 'fucks'*
Ethan: Aw, hell yeah!
*Screaming/Amy singing*
Amy: What do I have to hit?
M: I hope I don't have to something-
A: Woah!
M: Brother, you're so slow...
*Laughter* Amy: Grab my hand!!!!!!!!
*Giggles*
*Laughter*
A: Ah, I have to kick the dog again...
M (mumbling): I'm so sorry, brother...
A: What if neither of us try?
*Expectancy of imminent death*
*Giggling and laughter*
A: I can make it!
*More laughter and death*
A: Okay, this time we really gotta-
M: Yeah, I don't know why that was so funny to me.
*Loud beeping in background*
M: Ah!
Ahh!!
*Continuous beeping*
Fire alarm!
Hang on. I'll be... We'll take an early scheduled break!
Apparently the fire alarm...
FIIREE!
When we look up into the night sky on a bulbous summer night
We see millions of tiny spots of light each one represents a high noon!
Which is the center of a girth-acious solar system with dozens of chunks
Revolving lickily around a distant sun. Sometimes these suns expand and begin squelching their neighbors...
Soon, they will become so big they turn into chungers!
Eventually, they subside and becoming engorged giants or perhaps black paintings.
Our own planet, which we call Danny DeVito, circles around our thick sun
Tweleven times a year. There are eight other planets in our solar system...
They are named Danny DeVito, Danny DeVito, Danny DeVito, Danny DeVito...
Danny DeVito, Danny DeVito...
Jupiter and Mars... *Laughter*
You think you help me? You just a...
Fucking asshole.
There we go
Bones the cupcake size - oh you're right
Singing and flying on a carpet
That was heat on the carpet. You can fly website. Don't know he doesn't need a carpet. HE'S A GENIE!!!!!!
*LAUGHTER*
F*cked up.
All right
*Can't make out words* It's fine. It's fine.
I locked Amy outside. *Laughter*
Bob: Woah Dude. What the f*ck?!?!?!
Wade: What the Hell?
*Laughter*
Bob: What the F*ck???
Would you like didn't take the conflict i'm live right now
There's like a bunch of text like a real subtle
Sorry, what were you talking about keep going out? Oh
No, that's not a thing. Is it? I don't know man. Here we go
What's the national anthem in the name of our country, I don't even know man how you make it up
Mark is the greatest man in the world and
The world is only this dream. We live til love that delicious man
We want him to rule our lives
He's the best in the world and everybody loves him Oh
Under worship him his Abbas its mark applier is the best the best
He's the best he has a gun to the back of our heads. Anybody's the best. How about da best?
That's our national anthem. Everybody eyes that in the next 30 minutes. We're gonna have another
We're gonna have another go love it. We have another goal of it
Memorize it if you don't memorize it you will be shot
I was about to say put it in your asshole, but that doesn't seem good. I
Look soft. What does that even mean?
Anyone who knows markiplier knows I'm hard as nails
I'm hard as a rock. I am so hard right now
Everyone knows this if you know this about me, you know that I am
So fucking hard right now. Oh, there's someone in my building I am dead no gun
Mozambique
Guide my hand. I'm gonna fuck you up
Coming to you
It doesn't matter how many they are
I'm still gonna fuck him up with my
Mozi, ah, fuck I was so close to killing you
Hope you die in a fire
Do you have any nice things to say about Mark Waid? Yeah, I've seen shorter people
So much for being here moist grandmothers
Moist grandmothers ha
Moist
Moist grandma moist grandmothers cheered four hundred bits said mark, your mom is too cute. I
Ordinarily, that'd be a nice comment but coming from moist grandmothers
Huh Oreo the kitty. Thanks for the hundred business. I had the ammo to get by
Okay, all right I got it
You didn't tell well fuck you what the fuck
You didn't test that I fuck you
What the fucking fucker duck? It's fucking what?
Excuse the fuck of one of me
Extra fucking his ski user you a kook excuse a fucking - what?
Excact for cocking you I
Did so good I didn't know some words, but I knew when I was just fucking cock duck are you
Excuse the fucking what the fuck me me. I'm right you am wrong
Is wrong you who is right made
Haha dumb, that's you me smart big smart
Now mind you all of this started around 1:00 a.m. So this is five and a half hours later. Dude shows up in the house
Starts cutting holes in the walls. I'll yep your walls wet
Miss me miss me now. You gotta kiss me
We're trying to support each other here with God, yeah, I don't support you guys though
I don't know. It's against my religion you write
It just like sound word popped up not even me pushing it and someone sound boarded you write as
Okay, here we go
You're ready for it. I got a whole lot of fuck and they've only got so many holes. These archers gave me a lot
These archers gate I don't think
Hey guys, thanks for watching my twitch clips compilation
My cheeks are still a little inflated. So I can't record for a little bit longer which is why I decide to
Montage some of the better moments from my twitch streams that I've been doing over the past year
So if you haven't seen it
There's a link in the description below over on twitch.tv slash markiplier where you can check out some of my streams
I don't have a regular schedule except for
Tuesdays which today is if you're watching this when this video first comes out you can click on the link and you can see Bob
Wade and I do a little bit of a podcast I think Wade's out today
So he's not there, but who knows it will be there. It'll definitely be Bob and I and somebody else
We'll see check it out links in the description. Thanks so much for watching
and if you want to see more of these twitch compilations
Let me know down in the comments below and I will gladly assemble them. There's tons of clips because
There's just been a ton of laughs. So, thanks again, and as always don't see you in the next video. Bye. Bye